there are those who know how to move us
forward and unfortunately we're being
drowned out by a very powerful very
naive opposing force and um the key is
to to not to not listen to it and
certainly not allow
uh wise voices to be shut down
husband and wife brett weinstein and
heather heing are evolutionary
biologists who spend their time
exploring human nature
they're both on the political left with
careers as professors and they've
offered lectures on topics like the
binary nature of sex the inability of
equal wealth distribution to improve us
or our system and other leftist taboos
the two had been at evergreen state
college in washington state then in 2017
they decided to speak out against
radical orthodoxy i am talking about
terms that serve the truth you said some
racists
that sparked outrage and protests
leading to their resignations they not
only forfeited their tenure but also
their careers as they knew them
in our conversation brett and heather
explained the fallout from evergreen and
how they had to speak up knowing full
well what it could lead to
now their hosts on the dark horse
podcast operating as exiled professors
their new book is a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century evolution and
the challenges of modern life
in our episode we spend the hour
breaking those challenges down we
discuss the fundamental problem with the
phrase follow the science how we save
our collective consciousness
and what human civilization must do to
continue growing and progressing while
also maintaining our existence and our
foundations
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't let big
tech track what you do anonymize your
web browsing expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we will be doing
some bonus questions at the end with
brett and heather the only way to get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member head on over to
dailywire.com become a member you'll
have access to all of the full
conversations with every one of our
awesome guests bretton heather thanks so
much for joining the show
great to be here
so
you guys first came to my attention
because of obviously everything was
happening at evergreen state college for
people who missed that story um brett
you you both have sort of independent
stories as to what happened to every
green state college um but i think i was
aware of brett's story first so brett
why don't you start with explaining what
exactly happened at evergreen state
college that made you sort of a national
name there's no question i dread more
than this one because it's a complex
story and it's very hard to summarize
but
in short there was a we hired a new
president at the college he impaneled a
committee to generate some diversity
equity and inclusion proposals
they began to emerge the proposals were
clearly ill-advised and a threat to the
college they were also a threat to the
very populations that they were
ostensibly designed to help
i felt it was my moral obligation and it
was also my duty as a professor to
comment on changes at the college so i
uh stood up at a faculty meeting the
first time and i
pointed out why these proposals were a
hazard i knew that what would come back
would be accusations of racism but i
felt that
as a very popular and long-standing
professor at the college and someone
with
lots of contact in the faculty that i
could withstand
the accusations of racism
but things descended rapidly after
the there was a day of absence in which
the college administration teamed up uh
with the diversity and equity folks and
advocated that white people not come to
campus on a particular day i objected to
that on many grounds this was a public
college this was clearly a
constitutional question
and
um i was publicly accused of racism and
then
on may 23rd 2017 at 10 o'clock in the
morning roughly 50 students i had never
met showed up at my classroom disrupted
it they
insisted that i resign or be fired
those protests quickly descended into
riots the president of the college
withdrew the police
students roved the campus with weapons
students battered other students
students bullied other students uh um in
the hallways
and uh eventually heather and i
in washington you have to file a tort
claim before you can sue so we didn't
actually get to the point of suing but
as we were about to sue the college
finally settled with us on the condition
that we leave and we did so and uh we
have
started another career i guess as a
podcasters and public intellectuals in
the aftermath
and heather you also came under fire for
suggesting that for example men are on
average taller than women apparently
this is very controversial stuff
yeah this is this is very controversial
um
that never grew drew the ire of people
at evergreen as far as i knew um and in
fact one of the one of the surprising
things to people outside of evergreen uh
is that in our in our classrooms
actually we had very difficult
conversations far beyond the outlandish
claim that men are in fact on average
taller than women
but because of the material that brett
and i were teaching and you know as and
as in our new book
we were taking on questions of what are
the evolutionary underpinnings of truly
horrifying human behaviors like murder
and rape and genocide and war
and we were able to do that because we
had
honest classrooms in which dissent was
not just allowed but encouraged
and
and you know we began we began every
class by talking about
the um the misapplications of
evolutionary theory things like the
naturalistic fallacy which imagines that
what is is what ought to be
and frankly we had for instance you know
we had we had actual trans students for
instance in our programs who came
because they knew that we wanted we were
going to we were going to insist on
talking about the reality of biological
sex the the binary nature of biological
sex
and the more fluid nature of gender
which does not in any way put the lie to
the biological reality of sex so
it was a year or so after
evergreen blew up on us that i was
actually on stage with peter pagosian
and helen pluckrose of the grievance
studies project and james damore of
google memo and i was making that claim
that men are in fact on average uh
taller than women that a few activists
not associated with evergreen but from
the same mold
uh you know pulled the plug pulled the
sound on the presentation and you know
so that that just reveals as you are
well familiar with
that the activism is hardly localized to
individual campuses or indeed localized
to campuses at all so in a second brett
i want to ask you what do you think has
happened to college campuses because
this is a kind of new thing i mean we
did see an attempt to take over
universities and that was largely
successful by by some types of radicals
in the 1960s but this is a different
type of takeover it's a really
sensorious takeover it's an attempt to
close all the doors and prevent open
discussion from happening i'm gonna ask
about that in just one second first it's
time to talk about life insurance life
is unexpected and if you have people who
rely on you you really need to have life
insurance because you just don't know
what's around at the corner i mean you
could just go around the corner and
there is just a shark i don't know why
it's there but you know as that shark
chomps on your leg you're thinking
yourself policy genius would have been
the place to go why didn't i do that
sooner policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
well you could say 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save 1300 bucks
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
see the licensed experts and policy
unions they work for you not the
insurance companies you can trust them
to help you navigate every step of the
shopping and buying process that kind of
service has earned policy genius
thousands of five star reviews across
trustpilot and google and eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week thanks to an award-winning
policy option that swaps the standard
medical exam requirement for a simple
phone call this exclusive policy was
recently rated number one by forbes
advisor higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
really easy first you head on over to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price when you're ready
to apply the policy genius team will
handle the paperwork and the scheduling
for free policy genius doesn't do extra
fees head on over to policygenius.com
right now to get started policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice and
very important to get it right alrighty
so brett i was asking a moment ago about
what you think has happened to college
campuses because obviously you've spent
most of your career on college campuses
you know i went to ucla i went to
harvard law i've spoken at college
campuses for probably the last 20 years
and it's really only in the last i would
say seven or eight years that things
have started to get so radical that you
actually felt like there was a threat to
public safety based on saying things
that it might be deemed controversial
well first of all there was a threat uh
to us in particular we were told by the
police who had been withdrawn from our
campus that we were not safe there that
they couldn't protect us they had
actually been forbidden to intervene so
the threat was very real
for several years after that incident i
was invited repeatedly to to talk and i
was invited to to testify in congress on
the question of free speech on college
campuses and each time i was invited i
tried to make the point this actually
has very little to do with college
campuses and it has very little to do
with free speech
speech is impeded as a last resort and
college campuses are simply the first
place that we have seen this battle
now that may have sounded strange to
people but now that we've seen these
very same forces spill out into public
and affect almost everything i think
it's pretty clear i was right about that
so what is happening on college campuses
i think it's a confluence of two things
i think there isn't a frustration people
correctly detect that the system is
rigged and that it is rigged against
them nothing seems to work the
institutions are not trustworthy they
are not serving the public interest and
many people young people in particular
recognize that they don't have an
obvious path
in their future
so that creates a lot of desire for
change
that desire for change is meeting a
frankly insane ideology that we have
been coddling in a certain corner of the
academy and heather and i ran into this
when we were college students the the
last round of it was taking place in the
90s and we encountered the claims that
scientific truths which really should
not have been controversial
were actually political positions
designed to
to capture power
and it was nonsense then but what has
happened is that by creating departments
in which these arguments can be advanced
unchallenged we have created the
impression that there is actually some
body of knowledge that has been
discovered that invalidates the gains of
the west and so the anger i talked about
which is justified is meeting this
nonsense belief system and they are
moving forward together and instead of
challenging
the features of our system that are
indeed broken and in need of repair what
they are doing is aiming to tear down
the system and the naive belief that
something better will replace it which
is certain not to be true
you know heather one of the things that
that has been you know pretty obvious to
those of us who've been watching is that
i don't think it's a coincidence that
the attacks in the academy and and
largely in public life
have been on people who claim that there
is such a thing as objective truth and
that has centralized in science uh
science becoming a particular target of
ire is very odd considering that science
has taken us from
life expectancies in our 30s to life
expectancies in our 80s and record
levels of prosperity and technological
progress and uh and has been such a
contributing factor to the flourishing
of human life and yet it is science that
is that is being attacked specifically
because it does make claims that there
are objective realities in the universe
that seem to contradict this ideology
which is an almost bizarrely
paganistically religious ideology that
that we are free-floating souls that are
capable of overcoming all aspects of the
real world yeah now it's it's a
strangely biologically essentialist
ideology
uh in in some ways
um that imagines that um that really
does make the naturalistic fallacy right
that that says uh what we if you are to
understand what we have been then that
is what we always shall be and there's
no changing it and in fact um you know
our our argument and this will seem
strange uh for people who aren't
familiar with it and who imagine that
evolutionary biologists will always be
talking about the genes
is that humans are yes the products of
evolution and understanding what that
evolution has looked like
provides much fodder for understanding
who we are but we are more software we
are more about the software layer than
the hardware layer of than any other
organism on the planet we actually have
more flexibility to become almost
anything at birth than any other
organisms do
and so it's quite the opposite of a
biologically essentialist view
and the rejection of actual
actual evolutionary thinking
by many in the academy does have a long
history and it's largely about a
misunderstanding of evolution
but it's also exactly as you say in
service of an ideology which really can
be understood as religion
so when we look at sort of the attacks
on science it seems like the attacks on
science have not only infused the
academy but they've actually infused a
lot of our scientific institutions it's
been of particular annoyance to me over
the past year and a half to hear people
saying over and over and over the phrase
follow the science and what they really
mean is follow a particular person who
says one thing about his perception of
the science that may or may not be
rooted in science but what what i mean
you're both scientists you both live in
in these fields
what should we how should we approach
science with what level of respect or
cynicism should we approach the claim
that you need to follow the science and
from whom should we actually who should
we believe in this sort of sphere well
this is a difficult
question in large measure because the
term science covers a bunch of different
related things right so science in one
sense can be the compendium of wisdom
and knowledge that we have accumulated
it can be a process
but most fundamentally science is a
method one that people if they think
back to their high school education
could possibly formulate uh for
themselves but the key thing to
understand is that method is actually
extremely capable of figuring out when
we have a bias that is incorrect that is
really its its purpose it corrects our
biases it takes the things that we think
are true and forces us to see that they
are not true and it only works when you
do it properly it's very easy to do
something that looks like science that
technologically
uses all of the tools of science but if
you do it incorrectly if you do not have
a hypothesis that makes predictions and
then run a test that uh meets the
assumptions necessary to test whether
those predictions are valid then it
doesn't work and so what we have now
is a very corrupt system of science
that's plugged very directly into the
market and frequently instead instead of
telling us what we need to know it tells
us what we want to hear because although
the system of science the scientific
method is extremely capable it is also
fragile because it requires very special
conditions to work it is very easily
disrupted by things like market forces
and corruption and so when people say
follow the science you actually need to
focus on the word the that's the
indication that they don't know what
we're talking about right if they said
follow science then we would understand
actually they were talking about a
method and that it did not necessarily
point to the people who were dressed as
scientists that in fact what it does is
it points to people who have followed
the method correctly however they may be
dressed wherever they may be housed
and you know this is it's it's
frightening to watch people invoke
science for things that are as you point
out effectively a religious perspective
right belief systems that are immune to
falsification that are marching forward
with the advantages that come from
having been discovered uh through the
scientific method which they weren't
so heather why is this sort of stuff so
seductive i mean it really shouldn't be
because again science works i mean when
the process and methodology of science
are followed then the result is
verifiable which means that it works in
the real world and when we look at the
realities on the ground of of the parts
of human nature that are unchanging and
then the software parts that are capable
of change it seems like operating in the
real world is probably a better recipe
for success than whatever else is is
being pledged so what is the drive that
we are seeing from the most successful
and flourishing civilization in history
to take all of the tools that is used to
to reach this point and then
deconstruct those tools i i i it's a
frequent cause of bewilderment to me
what exactly is motivating the drive
yeah um
many things uh you know many of which
you have you have written about um
appropriately and successfully
i would say that part of it is exactly
the thing that we talk about in the book
that we identify as hyper novelty that
we live in a world in which the rate of
change
is itself changing so fast that even we
who are best able to adapt of any
organisms on the planet cannot even keep
up with the new conditions that we are
creating for ourselves
and what that means is that this method
which remains the scientific method
which remains the best way to access the
truth about the underlying reality in
the universe
it is inefficient
and it does sometimes uh demonstrate
things that we think are true and then
turn out not to be true this is exactly
part of the problem with the idea of
follow the science what you think is
true today even if you did use the
scientific method to get there may not
turn out to be true once you have more
evidence tomorrow or once conditions
change
so in a hyper-novel world in which
complexity is rife
and in which people are just looking for
ways to simplify their lives to make
meaning and to you know to get some
systems on set and forget
especially when it's something
as complicated as you know how do i
formulate my relationships how do i
understand a pathogen that is taking
over the world how is it that i figure
out how to get my sleep back on track
all of these are actually addressable
with the scientific method but most
people don't feel like they have access
to those tools and that is you know that
that is in fact what we're trying to do
in our book is provide a toolkit so that
people
you know certainly we provide a toolkit
for people with a lot of background in
evolutionary biology but our audience
in the classroom was people with no
exposure to evolutionary biology and
those are the same people who we are
also talking to in in the book we had as
students we were college professors for
15 years and we had as students
people who ran the gamut from coming
from very privileged homes to many
students on pell grants we had students
who'd gone through traditional schooling
and a lot of students who had been home
schooled or unschooled or
waldorf-schooled or montessori schooled
and in fact many of those students many
of our homeschooled students were some
of the most
most capable of problem solving and
working independently and knowing how to
work on teams and such but they often
came without
with with
substantial gaps because of course a
parent teaching a
their child doesn't necessarily know
everything they can know
and what we were trying to do and what
we try to do in life is
reveal to people that everyone can
actually follow the scientific method
that science is not does not require the
lab coat and the glassware and the
high-tech equipment
and that all of us should be able to
take responsibility for the owned our
own decisions that we're making rather
than
simply
answer to the authorities on the
television and i think it's that
you know what i give up i'm just going
to answer the authority i'm just going
to do what the authorities tell me to do
which is part of why we've landed where
we have i think there's something else
here though that that we need to
confront which is
the reason that we have a large number
of people espousing nonsense about the
way the world works and pretending it is
scientific has to do with the way that
our system has failed in one way our
system is incredibly productive and
vibrant
but it has been
unfair
and that does not mean you know what we
are told now by this movement is that we
will know it's fair when everything is
distributed equally that's nonsense and
it would actually destroy the system if
that were the result of it but that does
not mean that the way it is currently
described
divided is a reasonable way to do it
it's not even a good way to do it from
the point of view of maximizing what the
system produces the fact is opportunity
has been corralled by an increasingly uh
tinier subset of the population and so
what you're getting is
a lot of people who know that they are
not going to be on the winning side of
that equation for multiple reasons
because they haven't been
given access and they've been harmed
they haven't been given an education
that would allow them to take advantage
of opportunity if it emerged for them
and this is causing
frustration that makes it sound
reasonable that we must tear this system
down because this system is harmful
rather than we want in right
so
this is really a paired failing there's
a failing on the right where the right
has imagined that because the system
works obviously that it works better
than it does and a failure on the left
where the desire for solutions has not
been constrained by any process in which
people who know how to build things have
said that actually won't work right so
we are we are facing a mythology that
has filled a vacuum created by a very
justifiable frustration
so brett in a second i want to talk with
you about you know that that exactly
that sort of reactionary
move that we are seeing on both sides
where the right says everything is
hunky-dory because the left is saying
everything is broken and the reality is
that
as you say the the bare bones of the
system the the foundations of the system
may be good but we may need to fix
up some of the some of the cracks in the
system as opposed to blowing it up from
within i want to talk about that in just
one second first let's talk about going
to the post office
a lot of work goes into maintaining a
small business and like you got to save
money where you can save money so if you
have a small business you know that
there's nothing more valuable than your
time so why would you go waste time and
money at the post office stamps.com
makes it easy to mail and ship directly
from your computer save time and money
with stamps.com you can send letters and
packages for less with discounted rates
from usps ups and more here at dailywire
we've used stamps.com since 2017. we
don't waste our time over here which is
why we're still in business since 1998
stamps.com has been an indispensable
tool for nearly 1 million businesses
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups shipping right to
your computer whether you're an office
sending invoices or a side hustle etsy
shop or a full-blown warehouse shipping
out orders stamps.com will make your
life easier all you need is a computer
and a standard printer no special
supplies or equipment within minutes
you're up and running printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send and you'll get
exclusive discounts on postage and
shipping from usps as well as ups once
your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off no traffic no
lines cut the confusion out of shipping
with stamps.com's new rate advisor tool
you can even compare shipping rates and
timelines to easily find the best option
save time and save money with stamps.com
no risk and with my promo code shapiro
you get a special offer four week trial
plus free postage and digital scale no
long term commitments or contracts head
on over to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that's stamps.com promo
code shapirostamps.com never go to the
post office again
alrighty so brett you mentioned there
you know sort of the progressive versus
the the more conservative vision
conservatives may have a tendency to
sort of ignore systemic problems because
the idea is well the system overall
works and the left solutions very often
seem to be directed at tearing down the
system itself so the easiest thing to do
is to fight the left as opposed to
proposing a solution so in that category
you might say that you left current
attempts for example to get rid of
testing regimens or to say that
meritocracy itself is bad it needs to be
replaced with some sort of more equally
distributed
racial equity campaign the right looks
at that and they say are you insane what
you're doing right now is destroying all
possibility of success and efficiency
and flourishing
and really the and the left instead of
looking at the right and saying okay
well you may be right about generalized
meritocracy but how do we actually
change the system so more people have
access to the meritocracy they're just
saying blowing it up so what do you
think are some of the solutions that
that should be discussed by left and
right to a problem that i think both
would prefer to ignore in favor of of
these sort of reactionary defenses
well there are a few recognitions that
we just need to arrive at one is that
equal
equal outcome is not a desirable state
for the system it will not function it's
never been demonstrated to work and of
course it is a desperately unfair state
if we were to arrive there because it
punishes those who have contributed more
that said an even distribution of
opportunity is desirable to the extent
that there are people out there who have
tremendous capacity but that capacity is
squandered because they are occupied
scrubbing other people's toilets that's
a waste of innovation these people are
not innovating because they're too busy
so to the extent that what we want is a
system that does what our system does
well even better than our system does it
but does it in a way that does not cause
these um spasms of revolt we need to
make sure that opportunity is
distributed as widely as possible and it
can't just be theoretical opportunity
either it has to be realizable in other
words
freedoms people have but can't act on
aren't real freedoms so we have to
democratize the tools that actually make
people capable of using
uh these systems in order to
better the world to create beauty to
find insight to engage in compassion all
of these things
require a system that solves people's
needs more effectively than our system
is currently doing for a large fraction
of the population and if we thought in
these terms if we recognize that our
system succeeds in certain things but it
doesn't succeed in distributing those
things very well we could continue to
move in this direction and we wouldn't
have the upside down world where at the
moment conservatives are now
defending the gains made by past
radicals against new radicals who wish
to tear it all down right that is
evidence that our conversation is
incredibly broken that we haven't even
gotten to the basics of what it is we're
trying to accomplish and what the tools
are that would be necessary to get us
there
so heather the the sort of pessimistic
side of me says that i i hope that what
brett is saying is right that the fix is
possible because what people actually
want is the opportunity what i fear is
that
there may actually be a revolt against
the reality of
unequal distribution period that no
matter what you do there will be unequal
distribution and this is you know
whether whether you're talking in terms
of science and you know there are bell
curves in terms of results in in nearly
every arena of human life from height
distribution to weight distribution to
financial success or whether you're
talking about you know basic biblical
worldview that the poor will always be
among you as in as it says in the new
testament yeah the the that basic
reality which is that there will be
uneven distribution of results and that
in reality any system that tends to
benefit people who are
disproportionately right now we are a we
are an information society which means
the people of high
intellectual potential are more likely
to succeed than people who are of
average or low intellectual potential
but the numbers of those people are
necessarily the people at the top of
bell curves tend to do better than the
people in the rest of the bell curve
is it possible that that just too many
people don't believe in the notion that
equal opportunity is enough that equal
opportunity may not be enough because if
i'm given the equal opportunity i don't
succeed then it's kind of my own fault
yeah um i hope not i think not i may be
wrong
um
my sense is that those who are yelling
very loudly about the need for equal
outcomes are indeed very loud and they
do have increasing power right they do
have increasing power certainly on
campuses yes in media yes in hollywood
um but that many of the people saying
those things are just saying them
and that it is actually a very small
core group of true believers
who really do believe in a destruction
of an economic system that is it is
functional uh in exchange for something
that clearly would not function
that said the fact that there are so
many people willing to parrot the ideas
uh that sound like that kind of
destruction and you know favoring equal
outcome over equal opportunity
is is certainly worrisome
i will say that
the 15 years that i spent in college
classrooms teaching in college
classrooms actually made me
less of a misanthropist i went into that
work
really thinking you know what we're
doomed
you know there there are
there are just so many people who aren't
interested who aren't capable who aren't
going to
be on board to help us make a better
world
from practically day one in those
classrooms those evergreen classrooms
with extraordinary students almost to a
person and not to say that they were all
extraordinary intellects of course not
but almost to a person they had
capabilities that even they didn't know
about and that i couldn't see on the
surface when i first met them
and many of them because this was not an
elite population mostly we had elite
students but um but evergreen
took all comers almost so we really did
have students from across the range of
the american population
and most of them had been utterly failed
by their educations to date
many of them had not been failed by
their families although that was the
case for some too unfortunately but many
of them had been failed by their
education such as they arrived at my
doorstep and at brett's doorstep in in
the classrooms uh really thinking they
were incapable that they couldn't think
and if such people never run in to a
professor who has the time or the
incentive to reveal to them that they
are capable you will end up with people
who actually
can't think for themselves because they
have never been told that they can
i came away from that 15 years
knowing actually that the vast majority
of people can think want to think want
to be given the information with which
to make careful analytical decisions for
themselves and for others and that we
are
we are treating people like children not
because that's how they need to be
treated but for other reasons and
they're not good ones i would add one
thing which is
the pattern that those who opposed us at
evergreen were people that we didn't
know and that our students remained
quite loyal to us and in fact remained
enthusiastic about what we were doing
actually points to the answer to your
question what we were doing in the
classroom was taking the highest
capacity tools of science and
democratizing them which was our job was
to share these tools with students and
these students were of every description
racially we had trans students we had
students from uh every economic uh class
including some very poor students who
had eaten road kill because their
families couldn't afford anything else
we had veterans we had grandmothers you
know just you know across the spectrum
so i think the point is the experience
that we were having in the classroom was
so
vibrant and so
it was such a good proof of concept that
in some ways what people saw on youtube
was us getting caught off guard what we
were doing was working and we were
attacked by people who swore nothing was
working having not been in our
classrooms and so
i would just say
some of us have
done something that indicates how this
can be solved and we should be talking i
mean you know jordan peterson as well
you can look at his lectures and you can
see that people really wanted to
understand what hit what his insight
about the universe was and then of
course he's you know uh
been challenged in the same in the same
way so
there are those who know how to move us
forward and unfortunately we're being
drowned out by a very powerful very
naive
opposing force and
the key is to to not to not listen to it
and certainly not allow
uh wise voices to be shut down
alrighty so heather uh you know one of
the things that has been obvious is that
you're you're right i mean i see this
too that most people are just uninformed
about this stuff or not engaged and i
just wrote a book myself about the
renormalization of our institutions
including universities which has really
been done at the behest of a radical
fringe and all it takes is apparently
about 20 of any population in order to
renormalize the rest of the population
so long as they are intransigence and
they are aggressive and they are
incremental in their approach and it
seems like the the the lack of pushback
is really more to blame than the
presence of the radicals it seems like
there's just almost no pushback or at
least there wasn't until the last couple
of years from folks who considered
themselves in the middle politically or
center-left politically who might have
agreed with some of the policy
prescriptions of people on the radical
left but also disagreed with the entire
approach of blowing up the system
how do we convince people that it's
important to actually mobilize in
opposition to to this whether or not you
agree with the right yeah now that's
that's a great question and is one
indeed that we've been thinking about
for for many years now and i know you
have as well and
you know as as you write about and as
you just said the incrementalization of
the
of the progress that they are making
is part of why it is so hard to reveal
it to the exhausted middle right um
there is no moment at which everyone
everyone has the shade pulled from their
eyes and they can see what is true right
and so we have the sort of rolling
revelations
in which some people suddenly can see ah
yes actually it happened to me it
happened to a friend of mine i saw that
bit of footage uh and now i'm beginning
to put together the pieces so how you
know how
how can we
bring everyone into an understanding
that this is actually that important
i i don't have a global answer and i
wish i did but i think i think maybe a
global answer isn't possible it's going
it's probably not going to be done by
analysis it's more likely to be done by
by narrative
by telling true stories that actually
reveal that this this too could come for
you
and
boy there's there's a there's a lot more
to say but i guess
when when evergreen first blew up and
you know we had been seeing it we've
been talking about it among the few
colleagues that we could talk about it
with for a few years at the point that
uh it became public you know it blew up
in may of 2017
but at first when we were receiving so
much private support from other people
on campus who said i see it i know it
i can't stand up
we felt differently then than we do now
about whether or not that was an
appropriate response really we felt so
battered
and uh and
we've really we just felt so battered
that we understood that most people
would not have the
the core strength or really feel that
they had any other opportunities if they
took on
the institution on which they were
entirely dependent
and we were both perhaps braver but also
more able to see that a we wouldn't have
been able to live with ourselves if we
had not stood up to it
but also we
thought that we had a chance of being
able to escape into the world as much as
evergreen was in our entire world it
really you know more than most we had
you know we had two two tenured
positions um at this school and that was
our entire income so you know we gave up
all of that not knowing that's what we
were doing by standing up to it but
people see that and of course they're
scared of course they say you know what
i have a mortgage to pay and i have
children and i can't put them at risk by
standing up
but the question will always remain
you know when you lie in bed at night
and you're trying to fall asleep
what is plaguing you and if it really is
a question of
i'm concerned that i only have one
mortgage payment left in the bank and i
may lose my house and that's going to
put my family on the street you're in a
different position but many people
actually have more of a buffer and if
what is plaguing them is
i was silent
i was silent when i should not have been
silent i did not speak truth when i know
what the truth was i let someone else
take the heat
if there's any part of you that is
saying you should be speaking you should
be speaking so brett i want to get to
some of the topics that are more
specific to the book
in the book you talk about the sort of
frontiers that humanity
has
has attempted to breach and has pushed
up against you talk about things like
technological frontiers and geographic
frontiers and resource frontiers and
then you talk about what you call the
fourth frontier consciousness maybe you
can talk a little bit about what these
frontiers are and why consciousness is
in fact a frontier the thing to realize
is that all evolved creatures are in
pursuit of something that we humans call
growth the idea is a population that is
not growing
is a stagnant opportunity and when a
creature discovers a
a source of
well-being that allows the population to
grow that is evolutionary success and so
for creatures like us that feel things
it feels good but these things run out
right if you discover an island that's
unpopulated or a continent eventually
your population grows to fill it and
you're
back to zero sum dynamics
so
in such a case human beings will pursue
technological solutions that will allow
them to do more with the territory they
have that's another frontier but again
it's temporary
eventually people uh like all creatures
addicted to growth
will innovate other opportunities like
even if you can't come up with a
technological solution that creates
growth or find a new land mass stealing
resources from another population
potentially uh killing them in the
process while that isn't real growth it
does feel like growth from the point of
view of one's population so humans are
very good at rationalizing such things
and what our argument is
is that if we look back into human
evolutionary history
we know that human beings unlike
every other creature
don't have a niche in the classic sense
human beings have hunted marine mammals
they have terraced hillsides and farmed
they have
recovered nests from high inside of
caves to make soup
there's a huge diversity of things
humans have done to
find sustenance in the world why are we
different from other creatures because
we have a mechanism
for
rewriting our software for effectively
bootstrapping a new program for an
opportunity that no ancestor knew
anything about and then refining it so
it becomes
extremely efficient at generating
resources
and this process we argue happens
through a flip-flop between
natural human modes one of these modes
when your ancestors wisdom is well
suited to the circumstance you're in we
are in a highly cultural mode where
these things are efficiently transmitted
not necessarily literally often through
myth and other
packages that efficiently transmit it to
new generations but when we come up
against a
a puzzle for which we don't know the
answer humans flip into a conscious mode
and the key value of consciousness is
that we can plug our consciousnesses
into each other and we can parallel
process problems and we can come out
with solutions that are far greater than
the sum of the cognition that each of us
could do individually
so this is how humans figure out how to
what we call niche switch
and it should be triggered at the point
that you discover your ancestral wisdom
is not capable of addressing your
current problems this is a feature of
the current environment like none before
the problems we currently face are
immense and worse than that they are
changing so rapidly that they far
outstrip our normal capacity to adapt to
them so this is really
one of the central messages of our book
is that we have reached a point where
not only the rate of change but the rate
of change of the rate of change is so
high that we are inevitably going to
jeopardize our capacity to continue to
function on planet earth and the key is
to recognize that that's what we're
doing and to rise to consciousness and
bootstrap the solution to that puzzle so
that we can be here a hundred five
hundred a thousand years from now
so what what do you think heather are
the problems that are so big that brett
is talking about right there that
require us to switch over from culture
to consciousness because obviously as a
conservative i'm a very big fan of
received wisdom of the past and it seems
to me that these the shift from culture
to consciousness it could be triggered
not by an actual problem but by a
perceived problem and could result in
exactly the sort of deconstructionism
that we've been talking about before
namely if you've exhausted the culture
meaning that
not necessarily the culture has has
failed just that you've exhausted the
culture meaning that everybody sort of
reached the limit right there was a
point in in terms of geographic limits
where everything had now been found and
so human beings if you're going to
search for new geographic limit have to
attack each other uh it could the same
thing apply in the switch from culture
to consciousness where we sort of hit
the limits of culture everything is
fairly good but we are an aggressive
species and we're constantly looking to
grow and there's no more space to grow
and so instead we shift into
consciousness mode and end up actually
having an almost autoimmune disorder
with regard to our culture well you're
absolutely right um there is there is
risk to this conscious mode there is
greater chaos there is a there is a
higher error rate for sure
and um and culture by contrast is a time
of stability is you know it brings
stability from the past into the future
but it only works when the future looks
like the past and so we are certainly
not advocating for a move into pure
consciousness we are advocating for a
recognition that there are that there
are things in our culture that are still
functional and that we need to bring
forward into the future uh without
messing and that there are there are
also things that due to the rate of
change that we ourselves have created
and then other runaway processes that
may be due to us but that are now out of
our control uh we need to act with
innovation and we will make errors
but we need to problem solve and the
problems will look ways that nothing in
the past has looked so it's not i i get
the concern for sure and i have it too
and i know anyone any sane person i
would say should have it looking at the
world at the moment and looking what's
passing for progress right
but we can't go back we can't go back to
any imagined or real past
because that's just not the way things
go and i would you know we would argue
as liberals that we wouldn't want to go
back anyway but even if we did even if
we agreed that we wanted to it's not a
possibility but we should be able to
look and see what of the past is
necessary is fundamental is still
working or can be made to still work in
a rapidly changing world and move that
forward and you know use in fact the
sort of two paired concepts that we use
throughout the book two of them are the
precautionary principle and chesterton's
fence right and chesterton's fence
exactly speaks to to this concern that
you know if you have two people walking
along a path and they find a fence and
it's irritating to one he says let's get
rid of it
the other one should say to the first
until unless you can tell me what that
fence is for you have no right to get
rid of it i don't care how irritating it
is to you now but you need to tell me
what its function is or was
and and then tell me you know whether or
not it's still doing that function
before you try to get rid of it so that
is you know that is a conservative
perspective um but the longer in
existence something has been culturally
the more likely you should apply
chesterton's fence to it and so we apply
it we throughout the book we talk about
chesterton's
um breast milk and chesterton's play and
chesterton's gods right that that all of
these things come from our past
different moments in our past and they
have value and we overthrow them at our
peril so in a second brett i want to ask
you about how we do consciousness in an
era where you know the sort of parallel
modes that we're talking about have have
actually changed in terms of how we
interact i want to get to that in just
one second first let's talk about your
charitable giving so you probably have
an old car sitting around your driveway
right now or at least if you do
why would you want to keep paying for it
i donated instead to cars for kids it's
quick it's easy you'll get a tax
deduction and you'll be doing some good
your car donation is fast and free it's
usually picked up within 24 hours often
even the same day and cars for kids will
take your car even if it's not running
it takes just about two minutes they
handle all the details all the paperwork
all you need to do is schedule a pickup
and sign the title if you have one it
really is that quick and that easy and
yes donating your car is tax deductible
cars for kids works hard to sell your
car for the best price that means more
funds for their charity and a bigger tax
deduction for you hundreds of my
listeners are donating to cars for kids
like michael from nashville or ashley
from la they all heard me talk about
cars for kids and they've donated good
for them and you should join them as a
special thank you for donating your car
cars for kids gives you a vacation
voucher good for a three-day two-night
hotel stay donating cars for kids a
great idea you're helping people out and
you're getting a great tax deduction and
you're getting rid of the old car so
what exactly are you waiting for go to
carsforkids.org
ben you'll get professional service a
convenient pickup a maximum tax
deduction a vacation voucher and you'll
be doing something good that's cars with
a k k-a-r-s the number four k-i-d-s dot
org ben cars for kids dot org ben
okay so brett uh you know you talk about
in the book the the shift from culture
mode to consciousness mode and and you
say that we have this enormous capacity
for parallel processing that allows us
to play off of one another and then
almost grow exponentially by by
utilizing each other as resources the
internet has really shifted how that's
done so it used to be that one of the
kind of natural checks on what you call
consciousness mode was locality that you
didn't have access to every other human
being on the planet at the same exact
time and that also allowed you to winnow
out who you wish to share a
consciousness mode with to a certain
extent
you knew who was dumb and who was smart
in your local community and you'd find
the smart people and attempt to shift
policy based on on what the smart people
were saying to one another or the people
who know the most about a particular
topic the internet has shifted all of
that to the point where we can now
almost shift into our own
unique atomistic consciousness modes
where we find groups of people who agree
with us and we can do it right now
really fast and we can and we can evolve
these new
consciousness softwares
so incredibly quickly that it's it's
almost more risky and fraught with with
you know problems than it was certainly
before the rise of the
interconnectedness now that we now see
you're absolutely right and a theme of
our book is hyper novelty this is a case
of hyper novelty in the extreme where
even the way we interact with other
human beings which is incredibly ancient
i mean even predates language
is
a is so radically shifting that we have
no understanding of what this is doing
to our ability to think i mean even the
ghost in the machine the algorithms that
dictate whose insights we will see and
whose we will not
are having an effect on what we think
collectively our collective
consciousness has effectively been
parasitized by something which at best
has narrow economic interests and at
worst may have contrary interest to our
well-being it may um it may be uh
attempting to shape what we what we can
see about our own environment so the
danger you point to is absolutely real
in the book we talk about campfire as
the historical mode in which this
consciousness was deployed in the
evening when
one could not be productive
uh with respect to farming or or uh
hunting
the
group would gather and they would
discuss problems and parallel process
them so we have to figure out how to
make campfire work and you know twitter
isn't campfire that's one of the things
that we can say very clearly at this
point it doesn't have the necessary
prerequisites to function
as such a thing but the other thing i
want to point out is that this goes back
to the question
we were talking about uh with respect to
the the revolution that we are seeing in
our streets and on our college campuses
and elsewhere
that revolution
is very
focused on preventing certain people
from talking to other people right it
punishes you we're not supposed to be
talking to you ben
um and we will be punished for doing so
as you will probably be punished for
talking to us though uh it will no i'll
be fine
you'll be fine there's no doubt about
that and we'll be fine too but we're not
supposed to talk to you and the reason
that we're not supposed to talk to you
is that there is a desire to exclude
that which can falsify a cherished
myth
and so to the extent that you're going
to sell the idea
that men and women are not different
that you can switch on a moment's notice
that
it would be a good idea if the
well-being of society was
evenly
distributed that the west is a bad place
that has
always been about unfairness if you want
to sell any of these concepts what you
have to do is block the stuff that can
say that's not true and here's how you
know right this is why as you started
with scientists are under attack because
we have a toolkit that allows us to say
actually here's how we know that isn't
true right if it were true it makes
these predictions those predictions
don't turn out to be true therefore we
have to assume it's false
and us talking to people who are not
exactly of our
ilk is how we get smarter because the
blind spots of conservatives may be
something
liberals can see and vice versa right
you put those two together it's very
powerful and so those who wish to sell
us a false bill of goods have to keep us
from encountering the things that would
tell us that that's what's going on and
uh it is important that we
challenge uh
their ability to tell us what we may
listen to and who we may talk to it's
fundamental and if i can just add one
thing the fact that we talk across
uh difference ideological difference
demographic difference whatever kind of
difference it is
makes it more difficult to create
dehumanizing tropes and memes
and dehumanization of the other is one
of the ascending
tools
of of control and we need to resist that
at all costs we need to find the
humanity in each other and
given that the particular kind of
dehumanization that is happening now is
is largely political it's across
political lines um reaching across
whatever aisle you find and shaking
hands and breaking bread and looking
each other in the eye and sharing ideas
and recognizing that actually
we probably largely share values and we
may not i agree on where we are or how
we should get where we'd like to go but
we largely share values in the places
where we don't don't make the other
person satan right we're still human and
we just disagree with some of each
other's ideas that's it
i mean it is incredible how that basic
idea has gone completely away i remember
i was recently
in a bit of a hoity-toity group of very
powerful people and the subject of
political polarization came up and uh
they kind of threw the the conch to me
to talk about political polarization
because of course uh i am uh i have been
both subjected to it and uh and
obviously and blamed for it uh and one
of the things that i said is that you
know as much as i'm you know a very
politically active person uh and i'm
pretty strident about my politics i make
a point of talking across the political
aisle if you actually want to solve
political polarization it's really not
all that hard all everybody in the room
has to do is get on twitter today find
somebody who voted like you didn't and
say this person is a human being and i
enjoy talking to them they have some
interesting ideas not one person in the
room actually did it but it actually is
is relatively simple and it's kind of
amazing that even so much as that has
been basically treated as an athema well
think about think about the the game
theory here right you know and we know
the very same thing from the other side
of the political spectrum it is actually
rewarding to talk to people that you
don't agree with but you respect you
learn things from this it's a very
powerful process
because it is rewarding in order to
prevent it from have happening it has to
be severely punished and that's the
point is that what we are seeing
is somebody gaming our system of
incentives so that we forget how to talk
to people that we don't agree with and
that is it's alarming and it's also an
indicator of what they're up to that it
isn't honorable and it isn't motivated
by insight
so brett earlier you alluded to some of
the big problems that you think that we
are facing that require us to shift from
culture mode into consciousness mode so
what do you think are some of the
biggest problems that we are facing
right now
as human beings because on the one hand
i i agree that there's some pretty big
problems but i think the definition of
those problems
is is one of the root questions right
it's not hard to see how somebody could
take the sort of stephen pinker side
that things have been getting
progressively better and uh and that the
the problems we face are by historical
sort of comparison relatively minor uh
on the other hand we can kind of see
that western civilization seems to be
tearing itself apart a little bit from
within maybe not a little bit and that
the seams seem to be stretched so what
do you see as the big problems that
we're facing uh it's a little you know
we could go on for hours on this let me
just say
there's a we informally talk about the
pinker problem all right stephen pinker
is right right he may not be right in
every detail but he is overarchingly
right that we you know
frankly just the even simple details of
our lives we live essentially you know
better than monarchs of the past when
you think of all of the things that we
have access to i mean i have the library
of alexandria times a thousand in my
pocket there are incredible advantages
of where we've arrived
that said
it's not a complete perspective
the
danger of where we are is absolutely
immense so if you sort of take the
instantaneous measure of well-being
there is a tremendous amount of
well-being and it is widely distributed
it is not fairly distributed but it is
widely distributed if you take the
hazard of the moment then you'll
discover we've never been in greater
peril that in the past populations did
endanger themselves and some populations
actually drove themselves extinct
but it was never all of us together at
the moment what we have is a planet that
is headed in a direction that cannot be
sustained just literally cannot be
sustained we know we cannot continue to
go in this direction we also know that
we don't have a recipe for figuring out
how to correct our course markets simply
are incapable of doing the job of
figuring out what the hazards are going
forward in fact they have a very
particular defect when we talk about in
the book
the senescence of civilization is the
result of the fact that processes that
are extremely productive and useful but
dangerous tend to accumulate in our
system and as these things build up they
create greater and greater fragility so
the biggest problem that we have to face
is that we can't keep doing this and we
don't know what replaces it right that's
job one and the second thing i would say
the other major theme
of the book is that we are individually
very unhealthy as a result of all of
this technological progress and we do
live longer you're right about that but
we live longer we have anxiety that
would not have characterized our
ancestors we are physiologically
unhealthy we are socially unhealthy and
all of these things are indicators that
something that is generating the menu of
possibilities for us is simply off it's
giving us things that are um causing us
to do harm to ourselves and we have to
stop so heather you know the the the
sort of second
i certainly agree with the the second
because it's impossible to disagree with
the second obviously we see you know
mass obesity is the problem in the
united states not mass starvation uh and
that is an indicator that something has
gone wrong in in certainly an opposite
direction from what has gone wrong in
the past uh maybe you can expand a
little bit on what brett is talking
about when he talks about the sort of
senescence of of
capitalism the the sort of accruing of
specific problems that kind of builds up
over time maybe an example would be good
there
yeah well i guess
maybe this approach and i do feel like
we keep on
doing us an end run around your question
directly um
there is an it is easy once you find a
thing that you can measure in a system
which of course capitalism is very good
at
to imagine the thing that you've
measured is the thing that warranted
being measured and is the is the metric
that is
uh what should be paid attention to in
the system and it is thus also human
nature to pay attention to the metric uh
once you once you have it in front of
you and so
there is a reductionism that is being
conflated with science
so science is there there is um
science that is very narrow and there is
science that is very broad and
evolutionary approaches we take
in our lives and in our book
is a very broad emergent approach um we
ask questions of why to try to
understand uh what it is that we are
that we are doing and why we're facing
the problems we are
and the the more narrow approach that we
are finding so much evidence of in
um
in our supermarkets in our care system
in the blue lights that pervade our
homes and keep us from sleeping well
in the relationships that we can and
cannot have and that young people are
finding impossible to form because
they have been told that there are a few
things that they should be seeking and
are not recognizing that actually we are
we are all
more than the sum of our parts every
complex system has emergence
and so you know if it is both this is
both an answer and a non-answer again i
think but um i i point to
the error of reductionism
can also
close related to scientism which is not
the same as science that taking a
scientific approach trying to understand
what the underlying reality is means
that you may have lots of answers that
are true but then when you add them
together you don't get the complete the
complete answer and
at the moment we have lots of little
answers some of which are probably true
some of which aren't and
science because of the way that science
is now done in the west because of the
way it is funded in the us and and in
other western countries
is very much favoring small scale
reductionist types of science and not
the holistic larger question science and
that that is a big part of why we are
ending up where we are so brett in a
second i want to ask you about the sort
of flattening of humanity because i
think that that's kind of what we're
talking about on a philosophical level
is that
that human beings really are a wide
variety of things we're we're a
multifarious species we have all of
these different aspects of ourselves
when you ball those up together they are
more than the sum of their parts uh and
yet we have so many
we basically have a toolbox and every
tool in the box is a hammer right and so
it doesn't actually look like a toolbox
it just looks like a box of hammers uh
and i want to explain what i mean by
that in just one second first let's talk
about recruiting great folks to work for
you if you're a business owner right now
it's kind of hard to find the right
person for your job i mean we got more
job openings than people applying it for
the jobs right now the lockdowns of the
last year and a half created a huge
pent-up demand for places like gyms and
nail salons and hotels all of them are
on an epic hiring spree to accommodate
this surge of business so where do these
businesses turn to fill these roles fast
ziprecruiter and right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com ben
guest when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send your job to over 100
top job sites giving you access to their
network of millions of job seekers zip
recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and proactively presents
them to you
you can easily review recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers invite candidates to apply get
two and a half times more candidates zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day so if you own
a business you're trying to find the
right person you really should be
checking out ziprecruiter right now try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
ben guest that ziprecruiter.com
ben guest
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t just go to
zippercrew.com ben guest zip recruiter
is the smartest way to hire
okay so let's talk about sort of the
thinning of humanity this is a theory
that i've been sort of thinking about a
lot uh i've actually been thinking about
a lot in terms of of biblical story or
or myth depending on your point of view
about the bible uh and the the sort of
symbolism of how adam is is talked about
at the beginning of genesis what i what
i was noticing recently when i was
reading the book of genesis is that adam
is described in about seven different
ways right he is made from earth which
you could theoretically think of as
biological hardware and then the soul of
life is breathed into him which you
could think of as the software that you
discuss in your book and then he's
discussed as lover and then he's
discussed his father he's discussed as a
listener in the garden he's discussed as
the maintainer who's supposed to plow
and tell the ground and then the worker
who's supposed to support his family and
in all of these different roles
man which is what adam is right the the
word in hebrew for man is adam the man
is is all of these things at once and
yet we live in a in a system that
because
of what you're talking about the desire
for some sort of measurable result that
you can put on a chart has basically
flattened man into a series of sheets of
paper so you have homo economist who is
supposed to be just a purely rational
actor who acts out only through
capitalism and capitalism theoretically
supposed to solve all of your problems
and then when it doesn't people get get
angry at capitalism or you have sort of
you know homo libidness you have the the
man who's driven only by his sexual urge
and almost freudian fashion and the only
identity that he can find is in just how
people pursue their sex lives and sexual
identity is everything you have the
tribal man who is who's only supposed to
be a member of the tribe and we can boil
who he is down to his intersectional
characteristics and so we as a society
seem to have segregated all of these
things off as opposed to saying well
actually we're all of these things and
and maybe none of them at the same time
brett
uh you're absolutely right and this is
one of the places
that i think conservatives have the
deeper understanding if you've seen a
system that is coherent and complete
even if it is a mismatch for our present
circumstances there is something
essential about it so what we can say
about
any ancient religious tradition is that
it has stood the test of time and we can
say that about nothing no way of viewing
humanity
in the present it's all too new and so
what we are stuck with
is a very difficult problem the problem
is
if the ancient wisdom isn't a match for
the current world and we are not in a
position to take the time to evolve a
new system
what are we to do how do we figure out
which portions of the old we must
preserve and refine so that they work in
the new system and what we must generate
de novo and
i think
once you spot the difficulty of this
problem
you understand our current moment better
it isn't a simple problem and in the
book we are very clear about the fact
that we do not know enough humanity does
not know enough at this moment to
blueprint the future we do not know how
to describe the system that we need what
we do know is how to navigate in the
direction of that system how to
prototype and refine but we have to stop
pretending that markets are capable of
doing this job
markets are an evolutionary environment
that does not have our long-term
well-being in mind it is inherently
biased towards the short term and it is
putting us in danger if we are wise what
we will do
is recognize that we have never come up
with a better tool for figuring out how
to do things than markets but that they
have no business telling us what to do
they should not tell us what to want
because if we allow them to do that what
they will do is what we are seeing
presently they will explore every defect
of human character and exploit it to
somebody's benefit but not to our
collective benefit and um it's it's time
we divided those two things
so heather one of the things that occurs
to me here is and this does
cross streams with where we are
governmentally and maybe just in terms
of western civilization more broadly is
is the sort of fragmentation that we're
seeing
the actual attempt to solve the problem
in other words it's not just us falling
apart i think that right now you know
listen i took my family we moved from
california to florida one of the reasons
we did that is we were seeking
a different community a different style
of life
a different kind of
outlook from from the place that we were
living and so we moved and you're
starting to see the self-sorting
mechanism happen all over the west
you're starting to see nations in the eu
decide you know what the eu doesn't
speak for all of us you're starting to
see localism rising in the united states
california wants to be california texas
wants to be texas florida wants to be
florida and at the same time there's
this broadening because everything has
become so nationalized and
internationalized because the systems of
power have become so powerful whether
you're talking about international
corporations or whether you're talking
about international government or just
federal government as opposed to state
and local government it seems like the
the system of fixing this which used to
be find communities and experiment
within those communities and create
those campfires is now being overridden
by these broad national systems
incapable of actually adjusting on the
move yeah no i i absolutely agree and
you know as you know you're not the only
ones to have left california we have we
have both conserve other conservative
and liberal friends who have left
california finding what is happening
there untenable
and you know not because it's too
liberal really because in many ways it's
too illiberal and just simply
incompetent
it does seem like we are oscillating as
you say you know
too quickly between sort of the
individual level agency um and the the
transnational
uh you know
reality that we all live in and
yes many of us are seeking the many
layers in the middle where we could find
community again
and with the decay of traditional
systems like like churches and other
social groups and and synagogues
it's becoming much more difficult and of
course the last 18 months has made it
even more difficult to find actual
community with people whom you did not
have before
what
what we need is to spend more time in
physical space with one another um
looking each other in in the eye and you
know and feeling the ineffable and
sometimes unmeasured and unmeasurable
things that are true about humans when
they just share space with one another
and that is that is and is not an answer
to how to solve a planet's problems that
has seven
eight now billion people on it right um
but
but the number of people who are simply
feeling
totally isolated and who have the vast
majority of their social interactions
through screens which
quite literally does the flattening that
you were talking about with regard to
what how we understand humans
if we can reverse that i believe that we
can begin to reverse a number of the
other failings that we are experiencing
so i want to ask both of you a few final
questions starting with you you both
taught in colleges what advice do you
have for college students who are facing
down some of the issues that you had on
college campuses when you were there if
you'd like to hear brett weinstein's and
heather heing's answers you have to be a
daily wire member head on over to
dailywire.com click subscribe you can
hear the rest of our conversation over
there oh bret and heather i really
appreciate your time and uh thank you
for standing up for all the things you
stand up for and for the process of
knowledge making it really is an amazing
book you should go check it out a hunter
gatherer's guide to the 21st century
brett and heather thank you so much for
joining the show really appreciate it
thank you very much ben
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover executive
producer jeremy boring our technical
director is austin stevens and our
assistant director is pavel wydowski our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nichol audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola cristina title graphics are by
cynthia angulo the ben shapiro show
sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]